What’s up everybody?
Chad here with another very quick video lesson
for you all.
Today’s video less is not based on a TV
series, but a scene from a really funny Christmas
movie called “Elf.”
So the context of the scene is that Will Ferrell,
the actor, he is an Elf, one of Santa Clause’s
helpers.
And he’s come to New York to find his real
parents.
But all you need to know to understand the
scene is that he is in a shopping mall and
he sees a fake Santa Clause and he goes crazy.
So it’s a really funny scene to really learn
a lot with this scene DOWNLOAD THE POWER LESSON
just click there, and it’s an awesome resource
that breaks down all the vocabulary, pronunciation,
and cultural references.
And it will really, really help your English
Fluency.
So download the Power Lesson.
Sit back, relax and enjoy this scene from
“Elf.” Aww Yeah!